nous vous restez avec nous monsieur
boutisme nous allons voir précisément ce
qui est en train de se passer en france
la croix rouge vient d'adresser une
lettre à 5000 entreprises françaises
pour leur demander de financer
précisément cette aide aux réfugiés
rwandais les initiatives commencent à se
multiplier dans un contexte de polémique
les associations humanitaires et les
gouvernements en quelque sorte se
renvoient la balle en quête de carl
comment et eric gerber l'urgence porte
plus que jamais un nom toujours le même
rwanda expédier des couvertures mais
aussi des tentes et du matériel médical
le travail est aujourd'hui le même pour
toutes les organisations humanitaires
qui réfute l'accusation de mobilisation
tardive
né à leur encontre ces derniers jours
mais sous le train depuis plus d un an
des jalles dont on a dû sortir du mal à
les risques car la santé y rester y'en a
vraiment venu aussitôt qu'un était
et c'était les conditions de sécurité
suffisantes pour revenir on n'intervient
pas auprès des centaines de milliers de
personnes d'enfants femmes et hommes
comme ça d'un coup de baguette magique
il faut bien vous dire que ces
populations bouge tout le temps et que
il faut pouvoir s'installer une
logistique des centres de nutrition et
ça ne s'improvise pas pour ou contre
l'opération turquoise le débat a
longtemps divisé les organisations
humanitaires un désaccord que tous
préfèrent maintenant oublier pour tenter
d'intervenir au plus vite et de limiter
l'ampleur de cette catastrophe
humanitaire
malheureusement pour beaucoup de gens ça
sera trop tard c'est évident il ya là
beaucoup qui vont mourir et ce que j'ai
envie de dire c'est que il en reste de
toute façon énorme chiffre ça c'est
quelque chose de gigantesque tonnes
affluent comme on n'en a jamais vu et
que par rapport à cela il faut qu'on
continue à se mobiliser et très
rapidement intervenir très très vite
devant l'urgence la plupart des
organisations humanitaires manque
cruellement de moyens humains comme
financiers et lance aujourd'hui des
appels comme médecins sans frontières
par exemple qui cherchent des médecins
disponibles trois mois pour partir au
plus vite au rwanda